[ __ ] changes every day every hour every
week every year and people are bringing
up [ __ ] that i said in 2011
16 20 and they're like is this still the
case no [ __ ] changes they want instagram
to still be the organic reach that it
was seven years ago the attention
shifted
and the amount of ads and content have
risen and the supply and demand of
instagram is different and now tick tock
and youtube shorts and even facebook fan
pages which is now coming back
are better arbitrages for a lot of
content producers that are watching this
right now but they still want to produce
on instagram because it's
comfortable that way you need to get
comfortable with [ __ ] changing and you
need to watch it daily weekly monthly
and understand where we are in cycles
and what you want to do is you want to
buy in down cycles and you want to sell
it up cycles there's attention and
there's assets in the attention game
instagram organically is not going to be
that jam for you but youtube shorts and
tick tock and facebook pages is [ __ ]
[ __ ] changes get used to it